[Musik]
wow patch craig hallo mein name ist luca
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen folge
luca reagiert auf trends spaßt alter
jeder von euch kennen die youtube trend
also videos die derzeit aktuell einfach
total abgehen und immer wenn ich durch
die trends gehe sehe ich mindestens 40
videos wo ich einfach nur denke hey
warum ist das in den trends warum ist es
in den deutschen trend warum ist es
überhaupt ein trend deswegen schauen wir
uns heute mal zusammen die deutschen
youtube trends an so sieht das ganze aus
in den deutschen youtube trends also die
ganzen videos die der aktuell abgehen
werden hier untereinander aufgelistet
das erste video was heute anschauen ist
bonn sprossen sftp apocalyptic infiniti
produced by dj drama kann der titel
vielleicht auch länger sein wir klicken
einfach mal of play und wir sehen das
erste im video ist direkt mal fett
werbungen für in album ist es glaube ich
mit einem pictures
bikini bottom mafia bestellt doch bei
amazon vor hast ja nicht schon genug
werbung gemacht ob ich das sagen ich
mache gern jeder zweiten sequenz werbung
für den italienischen also nimmt jetzt
alles neu auf des is nice gemacht ich
bin kein rap experte das ist nicht der
hauptgegenstand meines kanals da gibt es
anderen deutschen raum die das viel
besser analysieren und bewerten können
wie er jetzt beispielsweise welche ley
noch was gereimt hat oder so ich kann
deutschland auch einfach nichts
abgewinnen weil es irgendwie nur darum
geht wer welche mutter fügt und wer der
beste ist und wer wen tötet und wer
gewinnt ist oder so also für mich ist es
keine
ja ich höre es halt einfach nicht aber
wenn ich jetzt mal durch dieses video
hierdurch skibbe sieht man schon dass
jede szene einfach enorm geiles von der
colour collection bis zu den locations
und ich glaube auch wenn ich jetzt
einfach mal auf play drücken dann macht
er das echt gut
also ich kenn schlossen nur aus dem
julius blog battle von früher
keine ahnung was er für tricks gemacht
hat aber wenn er hier in 27 minuten
video raushaut wo er einfach nur
anscheinend alle läutet ist und keine
ahnung was ist das schon beachtlich 27
minuten muss man erst mal hinkriegen
würde nicht wissen wie lange daran saß
also dieses video ist platz einzelnen
trends und das muss ich wirklich sagen
ist verdient oder schreibt mir die
kommentare ob das verdient ist rennt
platz 21 10 schlimme fehler die jede
beziehung ruinieren können und dann das
als sammler super cool video bevor das
video losgeht
die bewertungen sagen eigentlich schon
alles und zwar 1235 likes und 701 discs
oder sieg schon relativ groß aus egal
wie gut eine beziehung läuft mit einem
gravierenden fehler kann alles schneller
vorbei sein als man denkt der psychologe
er nennt seinen kanal der psychologe der
psychologe davon abhinge woran selbst
die beste beziehung kaputt ging
nummer eins sex entzug mit ich wusste
ich wusste dass die erste sache direkt
was mit sex zu tun hat lieber herr der
psychologe michael drittes video hier
sehen sollte sich kenne ich nicht das
ist das erste video was ich von dir
schauer aber mich hat das sehr sehr
stark an made my day
also eigentlich ist es genau made my day
ich finde es enorm krass dass der
psychologe 1455 abonnenten hat und mit
seinem video einfach platz zwei in den
trends ist wie krank ist das mit 1400
abonnenten 75.000 news vor allem
überlegt euch dass man das wären bei
meinem kanal das heißt wenn wir von 412
millionen aufrufe hätte so eine
steigerung ist es für ihn im vergleich
abonnenten zu view an nummer vier du
lässt dich gehen es war ein langer weg
und vielleicht steckt viel arbeiterin
dass ihr endlich zusammen seid aber an
eine beziehung zu kommen ist lange nicht
so anstrengend wie sie aufrecht zu
erhalten
auch gott danke für die tipps aber jeder
kann doch sein eigenes leben führen
dieses video war also platz zwei in den
trends ich weiß nicht warum es hat auch
enorm viele discs und wird auch nicht so
gut angenommen bei der community also
ich weiß nicht wieso ist in den trends
auf platz zwei ist illegal nicht rum
hätten aber ich kann es mir nicht
erklären hat drei in den trends des
tatorts synchro blind tatort day von
coldmirror ok brauchen uns gar nicht
angucken des eva diensten oder sollte
immer viel öfter da drin sein alter
meryl streep speed die golden globes
1000 seventeen
das hat innerhalb von zwei tagen 6,4
millionen aufrufe erreicht also mega
krank ich will das video hier ungern in
meinem video abspielen weil es halt eine
live übertragung von den golden globes
2017 ist ich hab das schon vor ein paar
tagen gesehen und weiß worum es gehe den
alten preis bekommen und hat anstatt
einer dankesrede so ein bisschen über
die allgemeine politische situation und
so gequatsche das video geht derzeit
voll um die welt habe ehrlich gesagt ein
bisschen lang zum copyright aber ist auf
jeden fall verdient dass es noch in den
trends ist weil es einfach bewegen das
thema ist react to german youtube
[Musik]
hat das schon mal gemacht
walter 700.000 aufruf x 2 160 tausend
abonnenten wieso kommt es so krass gut
an wenn irgendeiner aus england oder
amerika auf deutsche youtuber reagiert
ich mein deutschland überhaupt nicht
immer das was ich meine wenn sie sie
reagiert gerade auf du und du wirst
einen tischtennisball in ein glas wasser
und sie sagt so was great
seine mimik ist jetzt nicht die
allerbeste ich versuche das mal so ein
bisschen nachzustellen
wow patch great in den kommentaren hatte
sogar geschrieben text die kompliment im
hauptsache alessio geht es gut wird auch
geschrieben oder if you want is liebe
mit dem youtube germany mas apa red hat
der kater mit hut übels rausgeholt
german youtube grenzt an electric car
that could you watch nebel nie die worst
youtuber of germany ab website des tksv
klein tv beauty palace amiga pablo war
krank da wird übels darunter gehetzt und
vor allem alles nahezu auf deutsch oder
von deutschen leuten weil die kennen
sich alle bilder aus dieses sunny ist
also mit ihrem video auf platz 5 der
youtube trends und das ist halt schon
krass weil sie platz fünf der deutschen
youtube trends ist und sie ist
eigentlich engländerin oder amerikanerin
ich hab keine ahnung wie sonst heißt
einfach wie viele deutsche abonnenten
sie hat es ist beachtlich platz sechs
mcdonald's prank nur mit einen cent
stücken bezahlen von wow hd schauen wir
da doch auch mal rein unity was geht ab
aber statt und herzlich willkommen tsum
aber schon mal vorher lukas du hast
übelste energie wie kann man mit von
einer geballten energie ladung video
begriffen sind schon hier ein paar cent
stück uns besorgt und 2000 video thema
ist dass er nur mit einem cent stücken
mcdonald's bezahlt mega coole idee ich
weiß nicht ob das irgendwie aus amerika
ist es ist ja oft so bei
also trends die derzeit in deutschland
sind dass sie halt irgendwie vorher
schon mal in amerika waren vor 12
monaten jetzt sitzen sie hier im mc
drive im auto und er bestellt sein essen
und gibt jetzt glaub ich gerade das geld
ab die werden gerade übels angemeckert
man es gibt mir jetzt ein bisschen durch
also die gehen jetzt glaube ich hier in
mcdonalds rein oder so und haben jetzt
hier ihr essen und jetzt ist schwarz
schwarz schwarz
hier wird ein kanal ein ok warte er hat
am ende zwei minuten einfach irgendeinen
kanal eingeblendet mit musik im
hintergrund und damit das video zehn
minuten drei geht lukas ihr müsst wissen
bei youtube ist es so wenn ein video
über zehn minuten geht kann man mit rot
schalten also das sind anzeigen die
quasi nicht nur vor dem video kommen die
man überspringen kann sondern die auch
mitten im video ab und zu kommen viele
von euch haben an meinem kanal oft
bemängelt dass sich nur so videos
gemacht habt die vier bis sieben minuten
langen gegen und ich wollte das einfach
so machen weil es für mich schneller
ging zu schneiden und ihr müsst nicht
diese mit werbung aushalten und so
weiter und so fort und dann hab ich ja
selber letzten snapshot gefragt ob ihr
bock drauf habe dass ich einfach mal
videos machen die wirklich zehn minuten
oder länger gehen nur im gegenzug dafür
weil ich halt viel länger auch vom pc
sitzen viel länger schneiden muss will
ich halt mit roland anzeigen schalten
und da wart ihr als zufrieden mit
deswegen finde ich auch cool dass hinter
meinen videos aber auch nicht wie
gehemmt wird waldseer quasi eure
entscheidung war aber alter überhaupt
nichts gegen dich lukas also wenn du
dich wenigstens selbst vor die kamera
gesetzt hat dass du hast einfach den
kanal abc aber sonst muss ich sagen dass
das video nicht gefallen hat also ich
finde die idee cool ich fand es mega
witz ich wohne eine straße von ihr weg
und lukas athletisch zu zehn minuten
videos esel alter immer genau zehn
minuten
ok es wird auch in den kommentaren schon
krass behandelt und ja ich weiß dass das
video was ihr gerade von mir angeguckt
auch über zehn minuten geht und ich auch
mit vol anzeigen geschaltet habe
ich wollte einfach darauf hinaus dass
ich ein bisschen zu dreist finde einfach
am ende noch black screen und dann noch
zwei minuten einfach musik mit dem kanal
einzublenden die werbung schalten zu
können also ich meine bei mir geht's der
dauerhaft um content überhaupt kein held
sein
ich bin überhaupt nicht in videos auf
zehn minuten bzw über zehn minuten auf
joel am mittwoch anzeigen zu schalten
wenn es wenigstens die ganzen zeitmesser
content ist aber kein held und niemanden
ich finds halt nur ein bisschen komisch
auf platz sieben ist ein video von
tanzverbot und zwar mein einkauf vom 10
erst auf platz acht haben ein video von
fei lam ii bestler habe ich auch ein
bisschen angst vor copyright platz neun
unfassbar hier lachen gaffer ice unfall
am münchner olympia sehe was
we watch des video zwei passanten filmen
wie eine familie auf dem münchner
olympia sie über das eis läuft hören sie
mal ganz genau der unterhaltung zu
leicht bisher war es so dass da zwei
leute andere leute gefilmt haben die das
eis gegangen sind und weil sie so gesagt
haben wir hoffentlich fallen die reihen
oder irgendwie so die tatsächlich mal
seid ihr behindert er lacht die auswahl
die ins wasser gefallen sind und ruft
mich mal rüber oder lauft dahin das ist
typisch unsere heutige gesellschaft
yaman ich filme die hoffentlich wollen
die reihen dann hab ich ein cooles video
und kaufen können school posten was seid
ihr für spaß das alter wenn ich euch da
gesehen hätte hätte ich euch das wasser
geschubst und dann noch gefilmt wir
gehen mal noch ein bisschen weiter die
trends durch also aid prime ist drin mit
dem lied was die rausgehauen haben auch
größte scheiße also was die abgezogen
haben
falls nicht was ich davon halten soll
korrigiert mich wenn ich falsch liege
aber die haben ja glaube ich einfach
alles gelöscht ihre komplette präsenz im
internet um dann damit quasi nur promo
zu machen für ein neues album und zu
zeigen dass jetzt musik machen und alle
greifen so rum so von wegen wer
gestorben ist ich habe auch ich gedacht
das irgendwie vielleicht an silvester
bei dem was passiert ist vielleicht wird
einer von der rakete getroffen hat ein
auge verloren oder so ohne spaß das habe
ich wirklich gedacht oder andere hand
verloren das kann ja oft passieren weil
wirklich ab dem zeitpunkt so silvester
wurde so alles von den gelöscht und
alles weiß und schwarz und trauer
stimmung und dann ist es nur promo für
ein album beziehungsweise ins tor
ich habe überhaupt nichts gegen die elb
drei jungs sind alle mega korrekt aber
die aktion konnten nicht so ganz
nachvollziehen day und aya sind in den
trends die sind auch mega cool brawngp
ist drin floyd mit einem
skandale entführung misshandlung im
livestream auf facebook und das verstehe
ich jetzt nicht hier ist ich werde 16
bühnen ein türkisches video von einer
türkischen serie oder ein türkischer
film in den deutschen trend überhaupt
nichts dagegen aber wie kommt es da rein
es soll nicht rassistisch wirken
ich denke dass jeder von euch aber ich
verstehe einfach nicht wie sie die
deutschen trends kommen konnten haben
wir denn da cron crafter die dümmsten
fan videos es ist das was ihr vom video
meine damen und herren wenn es euch
gefallen hat und ihr wollte sich
vielleicht noch mal irgendwie einer
woche auf die aktuellen youtube trends
dann reagiere dann lasst man leichter
und bei 40.000 mache ich das keine
ahnung hier findet hier ein smiley
eingeblendet wenn ihr darauf könnte
meinen kanal abonnieren und verpasst
keine videos mehr und hier findet gegen
anderes video eingeblendet ist locker
auf total kacke aber man kann es ja sich
mal anschauen wenn ihr zeit habt wer
cool